voters are more willing to overlook or  excuse lies in dishonesty  when politicians from their party are  the ones telling the lies and this can  happen out of a sense of loyalty out of  a sense of well the other side is way  way way worse and in the highly partisan  political climate that we have voters  are already tending to seek out  information that supports their  pre-existing beliefs this is called  confirmation bias that leads to the  spread of misinformation and it leads to  the acceptance or at minimum at minimum  the indifference to misleading  statements over lies as long as they  align with your political views I try  not to fall for this